The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: We have
this definition
for the class object.
I've created the init for you.
And here I'm giving
it "self," which
is the first thing that
you have to give it,
and then two
parameters-- w and d.
And for an instance
of a car, I'm
going to assign the data
attribute named wheels
to whatever is passed in for w.
So notice that they're
not the same name.
And the data
attribute for "doors"
is going to be the value
that's passed in for d OK?
And also notice
that inside init, I
can do any other sort of
initializations that I'd like.
So it's not just assigning
variables from the parameters
to variables for my objects.
So in this case I'm creating
a new data attribute named
"color," and I'm
going to just create
it to be an empty string
OK, even though I didn't
pass in any color to my object.
So the question says, "Using
the class definition above,
which line creates
a new Car object
with 4 wheels and 2 doors?"
OK?
So this first one is
not right, because it's
trying to call the class with
a variable mycar for self,
which isn't quite right.
So when you're
creating your object,
you have to give it one less
parameter than what you have.
So here we're just going
to have to create it
with the w and the d.
So we're going to create
this variable mycar
and we're going to assign it 4
for the number of wheels and 2
for the number of doors.
And the number of wheels
is the first parameter,
and the number of doors
is the second one,
so it should be this one
here-- Car 4 comma 2.
So that's this one.
Perfect.